[Musique]
dans un restaurant
vidéo o les mouches se
ta j'aime entendre lesch des phrases
refroidir cette conversation
muette qu'sur eux
chaises en groupe sous le lustre
éteint
[Musique]
l'après les a fané
les fleurs deviennent des funérailles
et le
la tapisserie est un ciel sans
saveur
l'ensemble est comme une sortie de
la mort et de
mystère quand le faux jour d'hiver
tu les
couleurs de verre Non
déclarer que
tissu des
rideaux
laisse
filtreur
peut-on
eté pailler une
[Musique]
fen et l'horloge
calme-toi une respiration
au-dessus
elle règne sur ce
Silence ici
convers et que trouble parfois Au deor
unit
avers sur les portes
manteaux dorme les par-dessus
[Musique]
dans un restaurant
vidéo o les mouches se
taisent j'aime entendre les c des
phrases
[Musique]
Refroidir cette conversation
muette qu'on
lesch dans
groupe sous le lustre
éteint
[Musique]
le prés